SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND IN
IN START AT LEAST BY CALLING
ROLL.
A MAN SECRETARY YOU WAY OVER
THERE.
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA.
BROKE HERE CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO HERE TELL [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG HERE [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
NEW VARIANT [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK HERE REYES.
SO I HAVE.
THAT WAS EXCITING.
WE ARE STILL AWAITING.
THE SENATE TO GET INTO THEIR
ROOM AND WE WILL BEGIN.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
MY SON HAS A WATER POLO GAME
THIS AFTERNOON.
IF ANYONE SEES A SENATORS IN THE
HALLWAY.
I'D REALLY LIKE TO MAKE THE
FLIGHT
RIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO START.
MY SHUT UP ALL YOUR GUYS AS
MICROPHONES.
ALRIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME
TO AUGUST SIXTEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS SUSPENSE HEARING
ON US.
NOW ON SENATE BILLS.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED I WE HAVE
TO HONOR FIVE BILLS ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE WHICH REPRESENT A
LOT OF MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW ALSO
ONE HANDED TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THE HARD WORK ON THE BILLS
BEFORE THE COMING OF ONE THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR COOPERATION --
THIS.
I LIKE ANNOUNCED THAT THE BILL
PACKETS ARE DIVIDE BY SUBJECT
AREA OTHER AVAILABLE ONLINE AT
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IS WEBSITE WHICH IS
LOCATED.
AT EIGHT P. R. O. DOT ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT GOP.
LATER THIS AFTERNOON FOLLOWING
TODAY'S HEARING THE COMMITTEE
WILL POST THE RESULTS OF THE
SUSPENSE FILE HEARING ON THE
SAME WEBSITE MISTER BE CLOSER
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK
ESPECIALLY THE COMMITTEE --
FOLKS ON BOTH SIDES ANSWERS
PUBLISHED --
ANYWAY.
YES THERE WE GO THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF ON
BOTH SIDES IN BOTH HOUSES.
BECAUSE IT TOOK A GREAT DEAL OF
EFFORT ON BOTH PARTS MAYBE WE
DON'T ALWAYS AGREE BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE WORK
COLLABORATIVELY AS BEST WE COULD
COME UP WITH THE BEST RESULTS
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR. FOR HER EFFORTS --
AS WELL IN IN WORKING OUT A LOT
OF THE DYNAMICS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU KNOW AND I WANT TO
THANK ALAN FOR THAT COOKIES THAT
SHE DELIVERED TO OUR OFFICE
THERE WAS DOUBT PART.
ALRIGHT AND ONE IS NEW I GOTTA
GIVE IT TO OUR SHE STEPPED IN
MID TERM AND SHE'S DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB AND BROUGHT US
COOKIES AND BROUGHT IT'S COOKING.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH EDUCATION DOES
EVERYBODY HAVE THE DOCUMENT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE AGAIN WITH S.
B. THREE TWENTY BY AIDS SENATOR
LEYVA -- IT
IS --
ABORTION BY MEDICATION
TECHNIQUES AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS REYES A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK --
IN THAT GETS OUT ON ME I'M SURE
BE ROLL CALL --
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE AN
ANNUAL REPORTING AN ADDITIONAL
DATA COLLECTION [inaudible]
WITHOUT AND OBJECTION WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION AND A
SECOND FOR ALL THAT.
YOU PASS OR DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS ON THE REST OF THE
SUSPENSE WHILE.
LET'S GET STARTED.
S. B. THREE FORTY SIX GLAZER
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
TIMELY COMPLETION INCENTIVES
HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
S. B. THREE FIFTY FOUR
PORTANTINO TRANSLATION SERVICES
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION PLANS
OF COURSE THAT'S A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SPECIFY OTHER IS NOT
A LANGUAGE.
THAT I GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
S. B. FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN DODD
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TEACHER CREDENTIAL PARTNERSHIP
PILOT PROGRAM DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ASSIGN THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION TO COMMUNICATIVE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
DESIGNATE LEGISLATIVE IT YET
ANALYST'S OFFICE IS IN
EVALUATING ENTITY.
THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY DODD MEDIA
LITERACY MODEL CURRICULUM
STANDARDS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO MAKE
MEDIA LITERACY RESOURCES AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
AVAILABLE ON ITS WEBSITE.
THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. EIGHT NINETY FIVE WHEN AND
LARA VIETNAMESE AMERICAN REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE IN CAMBODIA GENOCIDE
MODEL CURRICULA.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
TO DEVELOP AND THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION TO ADOPT A MODEL
CURRICULUM ON LONG HISTORY IN
CULTURAL STUDIES BY MARCH THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE AN AD
DOCTOR ARAMBULA IS A CO AUTHOR.
THAT GETS OUT WITH OF
S. B. NINE THIRTY THREE ALLEN
VISUAL AND PERFORMING ARTS
EDUCATION GRANT PROGRAM.
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. NINE SIXTY EIGHT PAN
MENTAL HEALTH RATIOS A POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REMEMBER THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES
FROM THE BILL'S REQUIREMENTS
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT LOADING.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY ONE ROSS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSE CREDIT
FOR MILITARY EXPERIENCE DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
NINE MONTHS FOR THE COMING
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE FOR CONSISTENT
POLICIES AND ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN
MONTHS FOR COLLEGES TO IMPLEMENT.
AND SPECIFY THE COLLEGES ARE TO
USE EXISTING RESOURCES TO OFFSET
COSTS THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. ELEVEN OH FOR ROTH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PREVENTION RESOURCES
FOR PARENTS DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
S. B. TWELVE A THREE BATES
SCHOOL LOCKDOWN TRAINING
PROCEDURES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. TWELVE TWENTY FIVE GLAZER
IN ALLEN HIGHER EDUCATION
FACILITIES BOND DO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
S. B. THIRTY THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
MORNING ELIGIBILITY FOR THAN FOR
YOUR THE NECESSARY SMALL SCHOOLS
FUNDING ALLOWANCES.
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT PAN
INFORMATION ON ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS CLINICAL TRAINING
SCHOOL PERFORMANCE BAKSHI.
DO PASS AS AMENDED CHIU PHASE
END REPORTING AND INCLUDING.
AND INCLUDE CERTAIN ELEMENTS
MOVE PRODUCT PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY INFORMATION TO AN
EXISTING ANNUAL REPORT AND
ELIMINATE DUPLICATION OF
REPORTING AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
SP THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX WILK
ANTELOPE VALLEY COLLEGE
AEROSPACE INSTITUTE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
S. B. FOURTEEN NO SIX HELL
COMMUNICATIVE BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE PILOT PROGRAM TO PASS.
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
ALRIGHT MOVING ON TO GENERAL
GOVERNMENT.
EVERYBODY HAS IT.
I'M SORRY LET'S GO BACK TO ON
EDUCATION S. B. FORTINOS SEX
HILL THAT ACTUALLY --
PASSED ON ANY ROLL CALL.
MOVING ON TO GENERAL GOVERNMENT.
STARTING WITH S. B. TWENTY FIVE
PORTANTINO ALLEY COUNTY
ELECTIONS PILOT PROGRAM DO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS TO DELAY THE
REQUIREMENTS UNTIL THE NEW
COMPUTER SYSTEM IS OPERATIONAL
BACK IT'S OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
S. B. THIRTY EIGHT ROSS
ADDITIONAL APPELLATE COURT JUDGE
SAN BERNARDINO RIVERSIDE AREA
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. FORTY SIX LEYVA MOBILE
HOME.
PARK MAINTENANCE INSPECTION
PROGRAM SUNSET EXTENSION TO PASS
FOR THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. ONE EIGHTY FIVE HERTZBERG
FINES AND FEES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. FORTY FIVE NIELSEN AND
NEWMAN [inaudible]
NIELSEN STATE VETERANS HOME
SYSTEM HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
S. B. FIVE OUT TO PORTANTINO A
E. D. MACHINES ON COMMUTER
TRAINS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. FIVE FIFTY ONE WESO
CALIFORNIA ACCESS LOAN PROGRAM
FOR SMALL BUSINESS FUND TRANSFER
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. SIX THIRTY SIX WESSEL
OPPOSITE VAT GEOGRAPHICALLY
TARGETED ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DO
PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
I'M SORRY SAID THAT WAS S. B..
SIX THIRTY FIVE S. B. SIX NINETY
FIVE LARA IN MITCHELL INDIVIDUAL
TAX IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE
LICENSING ENTITIES CANNOT
REQUIRE AN APPLICANT TO DISCLOSE
IMMIGRATION OR CITIZENSHIP
STATUS FOR THE PURPOSE OF A
LICENSURE.
AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES DO PASS.
M. WITH REPUBLIC I'M SORRY THAT
DO YOU DO PASS AS AMENDED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. SEVEN NINETY TWO WILK
HOMELESS COURTING FINANCING
COUNCIL HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY SIX JACKSON
CORPORATE BOARD DIVERSE CITY DO
PASS WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
RELATED TO ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT WIENER
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELETE CONFLICTS WITH AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE BLOOM AND
MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING CHANGES
THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY NINE WIENER
COMPASSIONATE CARE LICENSE FOR
CANNABIS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ELIMINATE THE STANDALONE
COMPASSION CARE LICENSE ALLOW AN
EXISTING RETAILER TO PARTNER
WITH A COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAM TO FACILITY DONATIONS.
REQUIRE PRODUCT TODAY DOES. TO
BE DESIGNATED FOR DONATION AND
CULTIVATION AN ADDED URGENCY
BECAUSE AS A SEVERABILITY CLAUSE
AND A SEVERABILITY CLAUSE THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
S. B. NINE OF AYE WIENER FOUR AM
BAR DISCO [inaudible]
LORD FOR M. BAR CLOSURE PILOT
PROGRAM.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE AN
ANNUAL REPORT ON DEAL I IS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CRIME FOR
EACH PARTICIPATING CITY AND THE
CHANGE IN THOSE AT CRIME
STATISTICS.
REMEMBER THE PROVISION THAT
STATES IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE TO FIND
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT COSTS.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
S. B. NINE THIRTY HERTZBERG
CANNABIS BANKING SYSTEM HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
S. B. NINE FIFTY SEVEN SEVEN
LARA CARPOOL LANE ACCESS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION BY ONE YEAR THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
SP NINE SIXTY ONE ALLEN ENHANCE
AND FOR SURE STRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS DO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
S. B. NINE SEVENTY THREE DODD
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL'S
DESIGNATED DRIVER PROGRAM DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE
USE OF THE REVENUE THAT GETS OUT
WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. NINE EIGHTY FOUR SKINNER
STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
SB NINE EIGHTY NINE WIECKOWSKI
HIGHWAY READ RELINQUISHMENT DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. TEN TWENTY NINE MCGUIRE
NORTH COAST REAL AUTHORITY DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
EXISTING BILL LANGUAGE.
REQUIRE THE NCR A TO DEVELOP A
CLOSURE PLAN REQUIRE THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY TO CONDUCT AN
ASSESSMENT OF DEBTS AND
LIABILITIES OF AND SEE OUR A AND
ASSESS POTENTIAL FUTURE USES FOR
NCR A ASSETS INCLUDING USING THE
RIGHT AWAY FOR A TRAIL.
MAKING SOME OTHER MINOR CHANGES
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
SP TEN SEVENTY SEVEN WILK WRAP
UP INSURANCE FOR NONRESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REQUIRE CERTAIN DISCLOSURES
RELATED TO WRAP UP INSURANCE
POLICIES PURCHASE FOR
NONRESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT.
PACKETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
S. WE TEN EIGHTY SIX ATKINS
DEATH BENEFITS FOR FIREFIGHTERS
AND POLICE OFFICERS DO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL.
SB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN ROTH THE P.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO ALLOW AN
APPRAISAL OBTAINED FROM A
PROPERTY OWNER ONLY UNDER
SPECIFIED CIRCUMSTANCES.
PROVIDE AN EXPEDITED ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS NGUYEN EP SOLICITOR OR
AGE AND IS ACTING IN AN UNSAFE
OR INJURIOUS AND MANNER.
MODIFY THE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
DB O. MUST RELEASED THE IDENTITY
OF A PACE SOLICITOR OR AGENT
PURSUANT TO THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT REQUEST.
MAKE OTHER CLEAR FINING
TECHNICAL CHANGES PACKETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. ELEVEN TWELVE ROTH
SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATE
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
SP ELEVEN NINETEEN BELL LOW
CARBON TRANSIT OPERATIONS
PROGRAM TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
JACKSON PAID FAMILY LEAVE FOR
MILITARY DEPLOYMENT DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND PROVIDE
CHAPTER IN OUT AMENDMENTS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
.
RIGHT I'M SORRY FOR THAT WE
FOUND THAT THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HAD
RECESSED --
FOR BUDGET COMMITTEE BUT WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND CARRY ON
LET'S TRY THIS AGAIN SB ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE JACKSON --
WE TALKED ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY LEYVA
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ALLOW MANUFACTURED HOMES TO BE
PART OF THE EXISTING PROGRAM.
BUT CAP THEIR PARTICIPATION AT
1% OF THE TOTAL PROGRAM FUND
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
HOLD ON FOR ONE MINUTE PLEASE
I
DON'T WANNA RECESS QUITE YET
BECAUSE WE HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE
ON BUT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF
PAUSE.
AND HOPEFULLY THE MEMBERS WILL
STAY HERE
.
I EIGHT THINK YOU.
WE DO THINK THAT HE WANTED TO
THEIR ALRIGHT.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY TWO HILL RED
LIGHT VIOLATIONS HOLDING
COMMITTEE S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY ONE
BATES SAN DIEGO NEIGHBORHOOD
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE
DEVELOPING E. ANY BE PLAN.
IS ALLOWABLE IN NOT REQUIRED
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE WEST SO
COURT INTERPRETERS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE EXEMPTION AND
RELATED REPORTING REQUIREMENT
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTE HIM.
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO BELL
HIGH SPEED.
RAIL PROPERTY ACQUISITION DO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE WEST A LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AS WE TWELVE FIVE HELP OUR
DEPARTMENT INSPECTIONS REPORTING
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL SB TWELVE
TWENTY SIX BATES BUILDING
PERMITS FOR IT SS THREE DWELLING
UNITS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. TWELVE NINETY FOUR
BRADFORD CANNABIS LOCAL EQUITY
PROGRAM DO YOU PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL S. B. THIRTY NO THREE
PAN COUNTY MEDICAL EXAMINER'S DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ALTERNATIVELY
ALLOW AN AFFECTED COUNTY TO
REFER A DEATH INVESTIGATION TOOK
COUNTY WITH THE MEDICAL EXAMINER.
FOR ANY CASE WITH A IT'S OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
WHEN STATE VETERANS HOMES
HOLDING COMMITTEE SP THIRTEEN
TWENTY STERN?
ELDER INDEPENDENT CARA BICU IS
SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY
AND THE HOME LOAN PROGRAM DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL SORRY BAD
JOKE -- SP
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT BELL ROAD
USER CHARGE ADVISORY COMMITTEE-TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN PORTANTINO
DRIVERS LICENSE UP FOR FOREIGN
NATIONALS TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
BALLOT DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE
PILOT PROGRAM TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
GALGIANI TECHNICAL SAYS.
ACCESSIBILITY OFFICE HOLDING
COMMITTEE S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
SEVEN HELL AUTOMATED EXTERNAL
DEFIBRILLATORS AEDS AND
RENOVATED BUILDINGS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL.
AS BEFORE TO KNOW THREE LARA
CLEAN TRUCK AND A ROLL CALL.
SP FORTUNE ON NINE WILK
INDUSTRIAL HEMP PRODUCTION DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL S. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY GLAZIER
WINEGROWERS TASTING ROOMS
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
SP FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE STERN
ENDLESS SUMMER LICENSE PLATE. TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SPECIFIED
ALLOWABLE USE OF FUNDS FOR THE
COASTAL PROGRAM.
THAT IT'S OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
S. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE HILL
REPORTING CIVIL ACTIONS OF THE
CONTRACTORS LICENSING BOARD DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING CHANGES.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING SP FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE HILL STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL
SUNSET EXTENSION DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MAKE A TECHNICAL
CHANGE THAT GETS OVER THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
SP FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE HELL
BUREAU OF ELECTRONIC APPLIANCE
AN APPLIANCE REPAIR SUNSET
EXTENSION DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CHANGE THE NAME OF THE BUREAU TO
THE BUREAU OF HOUSEHOLD GOODS
AND SERVICES THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
ALRIGHT MOVING ON TO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
ABBE DOT IT APPEAR ALRIGHT SP
TWO SEVENTY FIVE PORTANTINO YOU
FOCUS SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THE BILL APPLIES TO
TREATMENT NOT TO PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION.
CHANGE GM EFFECTIVE DATE FOR
VARIOUS REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE
OTHER MINOR CLARIFYING CHANGES
LIKE IT'S UP WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
S. B. THREE NINETY EIGHT MONNING
ACQUIRED BRAIN TRAUMA PROGRAMS
LIKE IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. THREE NINETY NINE
PORTANTINO COVERAGE OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT TO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
S. B. FOUR FIFTY SIX PM MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR COMMUNITY
CLINICS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
LIMIT REIMBURSEMENT TO SPECIFIED
PROGRAMS MAKE CONFORMING CHANGES.
AT FINDINGS AND DECORATIONS ACT
IT OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
SP FIVE A ONE GLACIER.
DENTAL ANASTASIA DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MODIFY TRAINING
PERSON NOW STANDARDS AND
REQUIRED TRAINING CLARIFYING
BOARD APPROVED TRAINING DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF STANDARDS TOLD.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO REQUIRED
OFFICE WORLD HEALTH TO ISSUE A
REPORT ON ACCESS TO PEDIATRIC
DENTAL CARE REQUIRE THE DENTAL
BOARD TO REVIEW STANDARDS IN
INVERSE DATA.
AND ISSUE A REPORT WITH FINANCE
TO FURTHER INFORM SAFETY AND
STANDARDS AND OTHER RELATED
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. SEVEN OF SEVEN CANNELLA
DENTAL CAL ADVISORY GROUP TO
PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL.
SB SEVEN NINE SEVEN TWENTY SIX
WIENER CAL WORKS OVER PAYMENT
COLLECTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO INCREASE THE OVERPAYMENT
THRESHOLD TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS REQUIRE RATHER THAN.
REQUIRE RATHER THAN ALLOW
COUNTIES TO EXPUNGE OVERPAYMENTS
BECAUSE BY COUNTY NEGLIGENCE OR
MAJOR SYSTEMATIC ERROR DID DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION BY SIX MONTHS TO
MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL CLARIFYING%
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY THREE HELL
EVIDENCE BASED CRITERIA FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PROGRAMS
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. NINE OH SIX BELL IN
ANDERSON PEER SUPPORT MEDICAL
CERTIFICATION DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO SIMPLIFY DEFINITIONS INTO
STREAMLINED THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
TO JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY DELAYED
REQUIREMENT TO SEEK ESTATE.
PLAN AMENDMENT FOR PEER
CERTIFICATION SIMPLIFY FUNDING
REFERENCES TO ONLY INCLUDE M. H.
S. A. EDMUND STRAIGHT OF DOLLARS
IN CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS LIKE
IT'S HOW THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
S. B. NINE EIGHTEEN WIENER
HOMELESS YOUTH DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE GRANT
PROGRAM TO DELETE THE SEPARATE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
ENSURE YOUTH ARE INCLUDING A
STATEWIDE STRATEGIC PLAN.
INSURE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS.
AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. NINE FORTY FOUR HERTZBERG
LOCAL COMMUNITY PARA MEDICINE
PROGRAMS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. NINE SEVENTY FOUR LARA
EXPANDING MEDICAID TO SENIORS
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B.. ONE ZERO ZERO FOUR WIENER
IN MORE LOCK PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION PARTIES FOR
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO ALLOW
COUNTY STACK JOINTLY CLEAR FIND
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED BY COUNTIES
WITH STAKEHOLDER INPUT CAN
CREATE ADDITIONAL FIFTH PRIORITY
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF
SENIORS IN RELATED FINDINGS.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
S. B. ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT
SKINNER STANDARDIZES CLOSURE FOR
DENTAL PLANS TO PASS ON IN A
ROLL CALL.
S. B. TEN NINETEEN BELT GRANT
PARODIES FOR YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES. TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AS IF YOU DROUGHT CO PAYMENTS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. TEN TWENTY THREE HERNANDEZ
COVERAGE FOR REPRODUCTIVE
TELEHEALTH SERVICES DO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. TEN TWENTY SIX JACKSON
FALL PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
SB TEN FORTY ONE LEYVA OVERSIGHT
CHILDREN'S HEALTH GOALS FOR LEAD
TESTING DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE ESTABLISHMENT OF GOALS IN
THE REQUIREMENT TO ANNUALLY
NOTIFY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. TO
REQUIRE COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
DESCRIBE HOW INFORMATION TO BE
SHARED WITH PROVIDERS BY
PROVIDING IN BY PROVIDERS TO
PARENTS AND OTHER CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE THAT GETS OUT OF THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. TEN FORTY FIVE WIENER AND
STERN HOUSING CONSERVATORSHIP
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER IN SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO AUTHORIZE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE COUNTY OPTION AT A
REQUIREMENT TO CONSULT WITH
LABOR REPRESENTATIVES IN AT A
LABOR REPRESENTED TO LOCAL
WORKING GROUPS IN OUR
REQUIREMENTS REFLECT THE SPECIAL
NEEDS OF LGBT.
INDIVIDUALS THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AS B. TEN EIGHTY THREE MITCHELL
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL FOR
FOSTER FAMILY HOMES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE COURT
REPORTING AND HEARING
REQUIREMENTS REMOVE THE CAN GAP
PROVISIONS.
AVOID CHAPTER NOW CONFLICTS WITH
A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY AND MAKE
OTHER TECHNICAL CLARIFYING
CHANGES THAT IT'S I WOULD
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. TEN NINETY SEVEN WESO.
CASE MANAGEMENT REPORT FOR LEAD
TESTING DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
MODIFY THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
CASE MANAGEMENT REPORT THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. BE ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE ATKINS
COMMUNICATE IT ONE VISIT PAYMENT
RULED TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
SKINNER PLANT BASED MEAL IN
HOSPITALS AND CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE CDC ARE TO DEVELOP A
PLAN TO PROVIDE PLANT BASED.
MEALS ON AN OVERALL COST NEUTRAL
BASIS THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT PAN
COVERAGE OF RESTORATIVE DENTAL
SERVICES MEDI CAL DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE EXPIRATION
DATE ON THE PROVISIONS THAT
LIMIT THE ELIGIBLE POPULATION
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
SB ELEVEN FIFTY SIX LEYVA THIRD
PARTY PAYMENTS OF HEALTH CARE
PREMIUMS TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
S. B. TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT LARA
OVERSIGHT CERTIFICATION OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
FACILITIES DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
CERTIFICATION REFERRALS FOR
SUBSTANCE USE CONTINUUM OF CARE.
TO FURTHER SPECIFY AND CLARIFY
PATIENT BROKERING PROVISIONS AND
THREE MODIFY ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
TO ISSUE GUIDANCE LIKE IT'S OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AS B. TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT ROTH
RETENTION OF PATIENT RECORDS
HOLDING COMMITTEE SP TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE HERNANDEZ FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR HEALTH CARE
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
SP TWELVE SIXTY FOUR STONE
HYPERTENSION MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT SERVICES MEDI CAL
HOLDING COMMITTEE SP TWELVE
SIXTY BRADFORD PATIENT PROGRAM
FOR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. TWELVE NINETY TWO HUESO
MYERS AND DISEASE REPORT TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY SIX GLAZIER
CAO WORKS WELFARE TO WORK
REQUIREMENTS TO PASS ON ANY ROLL
CALL.
SP FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN
HERNANDEZ --
ON MADE DRUG DELIVERY SYSTEM DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ALLOW FOR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO
DISPENSE A THREE DAY SUPPLY OF
DRUGS TO PATIENTS.
CHANGE OPERATIVE DATED JULY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN AND
CLARIFY AND CONFORMING
AMENDMENTS LIKE IT'S OUT OF THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AS WE FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT HILL
DISCLOSURE PATIENTS PROBATION
STATUS TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
S. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR WIENER
MEDI CAL PAYMENTS FOR ENROLLEES
WITH SPECIAL DENTAL NEEDS TO
HOLD IN COMMITTEE.
S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY HILL
HEALTH PROFESSION.
OMNIBUS BILL DO PASSES MINUTES
REMOVE A PROVISION REQUIRING
BOARDS TO PUBLICLY PRESENT VOTE
ON PROPOSALS RELATED TO SPENDING
AUTHORITY AND OTHER TECHNICAL
MEHMET SECONDS HOW THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AS YOU ARE. ONE ONE FIVE MCGUIRE
AND GAINES AFFECTS OF THE OPIOID
TO CRISIS ON CALIFORNIA DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REMOVE A PROVISION
ENCOURAGING THE STATE TO
INCREASE FUNDING THAT COMES OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
MOVING ON TO LABOR AND HERBS.
EVERY GOT IT [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
COME MIND HUSTLE HUSTLE ALL I
GOTTA GET TO THE AIRPORT WHERE.
SO TO ALL THESE FOLKS.
CHARLIE IS WAITING.
IRATE.
THAT'S IAN CALDERON STARTER BY
THAT'S NOT.
SOMEBODY ELSE FOR ME.
THAT WOULD BE WRONG.
WE SO MUCH IF I WELL I'VE KNOWN
AS DOWNRIGHT SAD AND IT JUST
SOUNDED WRONG ALRIGHT READY.
AYE WE ALREADY ARE A S. B. SIX
FIFTY SIX MORE LOCKED JUDGES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
DO PASS THAT GETS OUT.
ON A ROLL CALL S. B. SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE PAN PENSION
DIVESTMENT REVIEW PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE S. B. NINE
THIRTY SEVEN WIENER LACTATION
ACCOMMODATION DO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
S. B. NINE SIXTY FOUR ALLEN
CLIMENT RELATED FINANCIAL RISK
DO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR LEYVA
CALPERS DISALLOWED COMPENSATION
DO PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY FOUR DOT
ENHANCE INDUSTRIAL DISABILITY
LEAVE TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL S.
B. TWELVE TWENTY THREE GALGIANI
HARASSMENT PREVENTION IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY DO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR JACKSON
PAY DATA REPORTING HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
S. B. THIRTEEN JACKSON THIRTEEN
HUNDRED I'M SORRY JACKSON
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT
[inaudible]
AND DISCRIMINATION.
DO PASSED WITH AUTHOR MEHMET'S
TO REMOVE THE PROVISIONS RELATED
EXPAND TRAINING EXPANDED
TRAINING AUTHORIZE EMPLOYERS TO
OFFER BYSTANDER TRAINING CLARIFY
THE BILL'S APPLICATION TO
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS REMOVE
PROVISIONS OF MANY IN
SUBDIVISION QUE THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. THIRTEEN TWELVE JACKSON
STATE VETERAN EMPLOYEES AND SICK
LEAVE DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE MITCHELL
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION
TRAIN TO PASS WITH AUTHOR
MEMBERS TO CLARIFY TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR TEMPORARY OR
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS AND OTHER
TECHNICAL IN.
IMPLEMENTATION AMENDMENTS THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
S. B. FORTINO TO LARA PORT
DREDGE MOTOR CARRIERS DO PASS
WITH TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN
IMPLEMENTATION AMENDMENTS LIKE
IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTEEN NIELSEN
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS PENSION PRE
FUNDING TRUST FUND DO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL.
AS P. --
FOURTEEN SEVENTY STERN
COMMISSION ON THE FUTURE WORK
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT LIVING ON A PUBLIC
SAFETY [inaudible]
WHERE IS [inaudible]
READY [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
IT'S WHAT YOU ALL BEEN WAITING.
FOR S. B. TEN HERTZBERG BAIL
REFORM.
DO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO STRIKE EXISTING BILL LANGUAGE
TO REPEAL EXISTING BEALL
STATUTES THAT EFFECTIVE OF IT
WILL BE EFFECTIVE TO REPEAL THEM
OCTOBER FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN ESTABLISHING NEW
PRE TRIAL RELEASE SYSTEM THAT
INCLUDES PRE TRIAL ASSESSMENT
SERVICES PROVIDE BY COURTS OR BY
PUBLIC AGENCIES CONTRACTED WITH
COURTS SET SUCH AS COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS.
REQUIRE THAT MOST DEFENDANTS
CHARGED WITH NON VIOLENT
MISDEMEANORS WILL BE BOOKED AND
RELEASED WITHOUT BEING TAKEN
INTO CUSTODY OR RELEASED WITHIN
TWELVE HOURS IF TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY.
SPECIFY THE DEPENDENCE THAT DO
NOT MEET THE CRITERIA FOR BEING
BOOKED AND RELEASED WILL BE
EVALUATED BY PRETRIAL ASSESSMENT
SERVICES INTO TEAM. TO DETERMINE
SPECIFIED INFORMATION INCLUDING
THE DEFENDANT'S RISK LEVEL USING
A VALIDATED RISK ASSESSMENT
INSTRUMENT.
REQUIRE THAT THE DEFENDANTS
DEEMED LOW RISK BE RELEASED
PRIOR TO ARRAIGNMENT ON THEIR
OWN RECOGNIZANCE WITHOUT THE
LEAD WITH THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
NON MONETARY CONDITIONS.
REQUIRE THE DEFENDANT STEAM TO
MEDIUM RISK TO BE RELEASED OR
DETAINED PRIOR TO ARRAIGNMENT
PURSUANT TO LOCAL RULES OF THE
COURT TO BE DEVELOPED BY EACH
COURT.
INCLUDING AUTHORIZING COURTS TO
CONDUCT PRE ARRAIGNMENT REVIEWS
AND MAKE RELEASE DECISIONS.
PROHIBIT THE RELEASE PRIOR TO
RAINMAN OF CERTAIN DEFENDANTS
SUCH AS THOSE DEEMED HIGH RISK
ARE CHARGED WITH CERTAIN
FELONIES.
ESTABLISH PROCEDURES FOR RELEASE
OR DETENTION DETERMINATIONS AT
ARRAIGNMENTS REQUIRE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION TO BE PROVIDED TO
THE COURT BY PRE TRIAL
ASSESSMENT SERVICES ENTITY.
ALLOWS A PROSECUTOR A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY OR THE COURT TO RE OPEN
A DETENTION HEARING BASED ON NEW
EVIDENCE OR CHANGE IN
CIRCUMSTANCES AMONG OTHER
FACTORS.
REQUIRES A JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
ADOPT RULES OF COURT TO DESCRIBE
THE PROPER USE OF RISK
ASSESSMENT INFORMATION DESCRIBES
STANDARDS OF REVEAL IN STANDARDS
FOR RELEASE AND DETENTION BY PRE
TRIAL ASSESSMENT SERVICES.
ENTITIES AND THE COURTS.
REQUIRES JUDICIAL COUNCIL SUBMIT
ANNUAL REPORTS BEGINNING JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
PROVIDING SPECIFIED INFORMATION.
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN THE CHEAP
PROBATION OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA
TO EMILY ESTIMATE THE LEVEL
FUNDING NEEDED FOR PRE TRIAL
ASSESSMENT SERVICES SO THAT THE
FUNDING NEEDS ARE SUBMITTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE ALONG.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S ANNUAL
BUDGET MAKES NUMEROUS OTHER
CHANGES NECESSARY TO SPECIFY IN
IMPLEMENT THE NEW PRE TRIAL
RELEASE SYSTEM.
THIS GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
SB ONE FORTY TWO BELT PRESENT
AYE.
VERSION INCENTIVE PAYMENTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE SP ONE EIGHTY
THREE LARA PRIVILEGE FROM CIVIL
REST DO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
SP FOUR THIRTY NINE MITCHELL.
LIMIT JUVENILE COURT FOR
CHILDREN UNDER AGE TWELVE TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO KEEP MINORS
UNDER TWELVE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF JUVENILE COURT
IF THEY'VE COMMITTED SPECIFIED
OFFENSES.
SPECIFIED LEGIT LEGISLATIVE
INTENT FOR COUNTIES TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO MINOR STIR EXISTING
FUNDING THAT GETS OUT
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. SEVEN FORTY SIX PORTANTINO
AMMUNITION TRANSFERS DO PASS AS
AMENDED WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO REMOVE THE THREE YEAR
INSPECTION REQUIREMENT.
AND REQUIRE NEW CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS TO PLAY FOR SERIAL
NUMBERS FOR FIREARMS AT LACKEY
SERIAL NUMBERS LIKE IT'S OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
SB EIGHT NINETY SIX MCGUIRE
AGGRAVATED ARSON DO PASS ON ANY
ROLL CALL S. B. NINETY NINE
TWENTY THREE WIENER CRIMINAL
EYEWITNESS IDENTIFICATION.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
VIDEO RECORDING ONLY WHEN
FEASIBLE SPECIFY THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT APPLY TO FIELD SHOW UP
EYEWITNESS IDENTIFICATIONS
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY TO USE
ADDITIONAL LINEUP PROCEDURES A
PREVENT THE LINE UP
ADMINISTRATOR FROM KNOWING WHERE
THE SUSPECT IS PLACED IN A LINE
UP AND MAKE OTHER.
CHANGES LIKE THAT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. NINE SIXTY LEYVA PRISON
SUICIDE PREVENTION REPORTS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO LIMIT THE
INFORMATION REQUIRED IN THE
REPORT AND MAKE OTHER MINOR
CHANGES.
S. B. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
BRADFORD.
I'M SORRY.
DO PASS WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
S. B. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
BRADFORD POSTING LAW ENFORCEMENT
POLICIES ONLINE TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
S. B. NINE NINETY WIENER INMATES
IN MYSTERY OF SAID SEGREGATION
UNITS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. TEN OH FIVE ATKINS VICTIM
COMPENSATION PET RELOCATION
EXPENSES PASS ON A ROLL CALL S.
B. TEN TEN BELL PAROLEES
SERVICES PILOT PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
SP TEN TWENTY FOUR WILK ANIMAL
ABUSE COUNSELLING HOLDING
COMMUNITY SB TEN TWENTY FIVE
SKINNER PROBATION ELIGIBILITY
FOR DRUG OFFENSES TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLL CALL.
S. B. TEN FIFTY LARA EXONERATE.
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT THAT.
DC ARE ASSIST FAMILY MEMBERS
WITH SIGN UP FOR ELIGIBLE
BENEFITS MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT OF THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. TEN NINETY FOUR ANDERSON
WRONGFUL INCARCERATION
COMPENSATION --
PROCESS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B.. ELEVEN HUNDRED PORTANTINO
MINIMUM AGE TO PURCHASE A LONG
GUN TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL
SB ELEVEN OH SIX HILL YOUNG
ADULT DEFERRED ENTRY OF JUDGMENT%
PILOT PROGRAM TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
PORTANTINO LIMIT ON PURCHASES A
LONG DENSE TO PASS AND BE ROLL
CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX HILL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SURVEILLANCE
POLICIES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY SKINNER
STERILIZATION COMPENSATION
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT WILK SEX
OFFENDER RISK ASSESSMENT
RESEARCH HOLDEN COMMITTEE A S.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY TWO GALGIANI
IN ATKINS THE TREES TASK FORCE.
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO LIMIT THE
SHARING OF CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION LIKE THAT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
SP TWELVE SEVENTY NINE BRADFORD
DOUBLE THE BASED TERM SENTENCING
LIMIT YOU PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY NE
LARA LIMITS ON TRANSFERRING
JUVENILES TO ADULT COURT DO PASS
AS AMENDED WITH CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS.
THAT IS HOW THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
SKINNER PEACE OFFICER RELEASED
RECORDS.
DO PASS WITH ALL THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE RECORD
SUBJECT TO DISK CLOSURE AND MAKE
OTHER CHANGES LIKE IT'S OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
SKINNER FELONY MURDER ALL.
DO YOU PASS IS AMENDED TO
SPECIFY THE BILL DOES NOT APPLY
WHEN THE VICTIM IS A PEACE
OFFICER SPECIFY PROCESS FOR
RECENT UNSEEN SPECIFY A
DEFENDANT THAT IS RE SENTENCE
WILL RECEIVE CREDIT FOR TIME
SERVED AND MAYBE ORDER TO PATROL.
MAKE OTHER VARIOUS CHANGES THAT
GETS OUT --
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SP
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE LEYVA
TESTING SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL [inaudible]
ALMOST DONE.
MOVING ON TO RESOURCES AND
UTILITIES.
S. B. SIXTY FOUR WHITE HOUSE SKI
NATURAL GAS FIRED POWER PLANTS
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
AIR BE TO USE EMISSION DATA
COLLECTED BY USC EPA EXPAND
LOCAL AIR DISTRICT STATE
REQUIREMENT DELETE THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS.
REQUIRE CPUC NCC TO ENSURE
RELIABILITY AND HUMAN ESTATE
ENERGY ENVIRONMENT POLICY GOALS
THAT GETS OUT OF THE REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
S. B. SEVENTY ONE WIENER SOLID
WASTE HAULERS HOLDING COMMITTEE
SP ONE SIXTY EIGHT WITKOWSKI
RECYCLED CONTENT BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS TO PASS FOR THEM WITH
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE BILL TO
PLASTIC CONTENT STANDARDS ONLY
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
SP TWU TWELVE JACKSON.
FOR S. B. TWO THIRTY SEVEN
HERTZBERG REMOVE THE CAP ON
DIRECT ACCESS ELECTRICITY
SERVICE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DIRECT THE CPUC TO CONSIDER
RECOMMEND AN INCREASE IN DIRECT
ACCESS THAT GETS OUT.
ON A ROLL CALL.
ESPYS TWO SIXTY TWO WHITE CAO
SKI CLIMATE ADAPTATION HOLDING
COMMITTEE SP FOUR FIFTY TWO
GLAZIER THE BOTTLE BILL. TO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE
PROVISIONS RELATED TO THE PILOT
PROGRAM BACK IT'S HOW THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. FIVE EIGHTEEN BERRYHILL
TWELVE MONTHS FISHING LICENSE TO
PASS WITHIN A ROLL CALL SB SEVEN
HUNDRED WIENER ENERGY STORAGE.
S. G. IP EXTENSION DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE CPUC TO
ENSURE.
S. GAAP AYE PROJECTS REDUCE
EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES
AND PROHIBIT THE PROGRAM FROM
FUNDING FOSSIL FUEL GENERATION
LIKE IT'S HOW THE REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO SKINNER
BUILDING ENERGY USE DATA DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE G. U.
I. REQUIREMENT THAT GETS HOW THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
SP EIGHT THIRTY FOUR JACKSON
OFFSHORE OIL LEASES DO PASS ON
TO BE ROLL CALL S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE GLACIER BAN SMOKING
AND AND STATE PARKS TO PASS WITH
OTHERS MINUTES TO LIMIT BILL TO
NON BEACH PARK SECONDS OUT OF
THE ROLL CALL.
SP EIGHT THIRTY SIX GLAZIER BAN
SMOKING ON STATE BEACHES DO PASS
WITH TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS WITHIN
THE ROLL CALL.
S. B. EIGHT EIGHTY ONE WILL
KOWSKI FLOOD CONTROL DO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL S. B. NINE
NINETEEN DIED STREAM GAGES STEAM.
STREAM GAUGES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. NINE FIFTY FIVE NIELSEN OR
BILL DAM CITIZEN ADVISORY
COMMISSION TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO REVISE AND
UNCODIFIED LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
PLACE THE COMMISSION AT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND
MAKE THEIR SECRETARY THE CHAIR
AT STATE DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTATIVES REVISED DUTIES
AND MEETING REQUIREMENTS REMOVE
GENERAL FUND PROVISIONS.
AND THE STATE MANDATE THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. NINE SIXTY SIX WIENER
ONSITE WATER TREATMENT TO PASS
WITH MOMENTS TO ENSURE ANY
ADVERSE IMPACTS ON LOCAL WATER
PURVEYORS ARE MITIGATED THAT
GETS OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
SP ONE THOUSAND LARA
PROPORTIONAL DISTIBUTION OF
ELECTRICAL VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE DOPASS AS
AMENDED TO PROVIDE C. C.
DISCRETION CONSISTENT WITH STATE
ENERGY ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES
THAT GETS OUT REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
S. B. TEN THIRTEEN LARA. TO
MANAGE TO CLARIFY THE DIDN'T
DEFINITION OF SUBSTITUTE REMOVE
LOWER RISK FROM THE CRITERIA
CONSIDERED TO MODIFY A DEADLINE
MAKE A TECHNICAL CLARIFICATION
REGARDING SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS
CLARIFYING THE INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
ALLOW THE AIR BE TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS IF THE EPA ALLOWS A
PREVIOUSLY PROHIBITED CHEMICAL
PURSUANT TO SNAP BACK IS HOW THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. TEN FOURTEEN SKINNER
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MILES STANDARD
IN INCENTIVES PROGRAM ZERO
MISSIONS TNC VEHICLES TO PASS ON
TO BE ROLL CALL.
S. B. TEN FIFTEEN ALLEN CLIMATE
RESILIENCY PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE SP TEN SEVENTEEN ALLEN
GILL NET FISHERY BUYOUT.
DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT FROM UP TO
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND TO UP TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND FROM PERMITS
HE'S WHO VOLUNTARILY SURRENDER.
DRIFT GILL NET AS SPECIFIED THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
SB TEN SEVENTY TWO LEYVA
REGIONAL CLIMATE COLLABORATIVE
TO PASS WITH AUTHOR MEMBERS TO
REVISE THE DEFINITIONS OF
CAPACITY BUILDING COLLABORATIVE
IN UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITY.
DELETE PROVISIONS RELATING TO
EXISTING STATE FUNDING PROGRAMS
INSTEAD REQUIRE THE COUNCIL TO
VOLUNTARILY DEVELOP TECHNICAL
ASSISTANT I LINE'S LIKE IT'S OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
PORTANTINO UPPER LA WORKING
GROUP AND RIVER RANGERS PROGRAM
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL S. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE HERTZBERG
ENERGY EFFICIENCY CUSTOM.
MEASURE PROCESS DO PASSES
MANAGEMENT CHANGES REGARDING
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION TIMELINES
AND PROCEDURES THAT GET THAT
WOULD REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
SB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN HERTZBERG
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS WELLS TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENT TO CLARIFY
DOCTOR AND STATE LANDS
COMMISSION MAY ALSO SEEK OTHER
FINANCIAL ASSURANCES THAT CAN
TELL THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. TWELVE FIFTEEN HERTZBERG
SEWER SERVICE EXTENSION DO PASS
WITH MEMBERS PROVIDE AN OPT OUT
PROVISION THAT IS HOW THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY JACKSON FIRE
PREVENTION PROTECTION AND
PREVENTION TO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS ON VOTING.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY THREE
PORTANTINO OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL MICRO PLASTIC STRATEGY
DO PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL.
SB THIRTY A ONE BALLOT DAM DALMA
IN FLOOD IT PROJECT PERMITTING
DO PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL.
S. B. THIRTEEN ON AYE MCGUIRE
OMNIBUS FISHING S. B. THIRTEEN
TEN MCGUIRE DIED UNITS CRAP DO
PASSED THE MEMBERS TO CHANGE
APPROPRIATIONS WHEN ALLOCATION
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDS.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING.
S. B. THIRTEEN ELEVEN BERRYHILL
COMBINED HUNTING AND FISHING
LICENSE HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN GLACIER
CARNEGIE STATE RECREATION AREA
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX ALLEN
SUSTAINABLE FOOD PACKAGING.
I'M SORRY S. B. THREE THIRTEEN
THIRTY FIVE ALLEN.
SUSTAINABLE FOOD PACKAGING DO
PASS WITH AUTHORED AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY ALL VENDORS ON STATE
PROPERTY MUST COMPLY THE PERSIAN
VISIONS OF THE BILL THAT GETS
OUT OF THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE STERN
MICROGRAMS DO PASS.
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN STERN
ENERGY STORAGE PROCUREMENT
HOLDING COMMITTEE S. P. S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN ACT IN SAN
DIEGO RIVER CONSERVANCY DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
SB THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE SKINNER
GREEN RENEWABLE HYDROGEN TO PASS
IS MEANT TO REMOVE PILOT
PROJECTS REQUIREMENT.
THAT GETS OUT REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX HILL
TNC ACCESSIBILITY TO PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT IT'S OUT
ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
PORTANTINO MICHAEL PLASTICS AND
DRINKING WATER TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SP FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
LEYVA ELECTRICITY TARIFF TO
SUPPORT BUS FLEET
ELECTRIFICATION HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY HUESO --
MEASURING RENEWABLE BIO METHANE
PROCUREMENT.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
CPUC TO CONSIDER ADOPTION OF BY
A MEAN THING PROCUREMENT GOALS
ON TARGETS THAT ARE ONE IN.
REPAIR INTEREST TO COST
EFFECTIVE IN THREE FOR THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENERGY
GOALS THAT GETS OUT WE
REPUBLICAN SOMEBODY IN.
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR HILL
CPUC AUTHORITY TO CONTRACT WITH
CHP AND SHERIFF'S FOR
ENFORCEMENT OF VEHICLE
REGULATIONS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
SP FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN STERN
BUILD AND TO BUILD INTACT GHG
REDUCTION ROLL CALL.
S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
STERN ICONIC AFRICAN SPECIES
PROTECTION ACT TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
ALRIGHT S. B. AND MANY NOT
ARRIVE IN TAXES THEIR BODY HAVE
IT.
IRATE THE SHOULD GO QUICK S. B.
TWO TWENTY SEVEN DE LEóN LOCAL
SCHOOLS IN COLLEGE BONTA
CONTRIBUTION FUND TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE AS WE
TO SEVENTY FOUR GLAZER FEDERAL
TAX AUDIT PROCEDURES TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL.
S. B. THREE FORTY THREE BRADFORD
CARE SAW HOUSING TRACT DO PASS
AS AMENDED REMOVE THE DEDUCTION
FOR UNREIMBURSED EXPENSES THAT
GETS OUT REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
S. B. FIVE THIRTY NINE DALY ON
COLLEGE ACCESS TAX CREDIT TO
PASS WITH.
AMENDED WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO INCREASE THE TOTAL AVAILABLE
CREDIT STE ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN TO MODIFY HOW FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED BACK IT'S HOW THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
SB NINE TWENTY FOUR MORALE
EMERGENT SEE STATE ACTIVE DUTY
INCOME EXCLUSION HOLDING
COMMITTEE S. B. TEN FIFTY SIX
SPELL COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS IN
UNDEVELOPED PROPERTY HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
SB -- ELEVEN
FIFTEEN HILL PROPERTY TAX
WELFARE EXEMPTION CAP DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO RAISE THE CAP TO
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS
HOW THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
GLAZIER ELEVEN EIGHTIES.
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY TWO RENTERS TAX
CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE S. B.
TWELVE FOURTEEN PORTANTINO
TEACHERS DEVELOPMENT EXPENSE
DEDUCTION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE MORE
LOT FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
REPORTING HOLDING COMMITTEE SP
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR HERNANDEZ
NONPROFITS RESTORE SALES AND USE
TAX EXEMPTION DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
SP FIFTEEN AWAY MCGUIRE
VOLUNTARY JUST.
FRIENDS THIS IS THE END OF OUR
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GO HOME